let's say you're building a machine
learning system and you're trying to
decide whether or not to use an
end-to-end approach let's take a look at
some of the pros and cons of entering
deep learning so that you can come away
with some guidelines or whether or not
and enter an approach it seems promising
for your application here are some of
the benefits of applying end-to-end
learning first is that intend learning
really just lets the data speak so if
you have enough X comma Y data then
whatever is the most appropriate
function mapping from X to Y if you
train a big enough neural network
hopefully then your network will figure
it out and by having a pure machine
learning approach your neural network
learning an input from X or Y may be
more able to capture what other
statistics are in the data rather than
being forced to reflect human
preconceptions so for example in the
case of speech recognition earlier
speech systems had this notion of a
phoneme which was a basic unit of sound
like our inter for the word camp and I
think that phonemes are an artifact
created by human linguist I actually
think they're phonemes are a fantasy of
language that are a reasonable
description of language but it's not
obvious that you want to force your
learning algorithm to think in phonemes
and if you let your learning algorithm
learn whatever representation they want
to learn rather than forcing your
learning algorithm to use phonemes as a
representation then there's overall
performance might end up being better
the second benefit that entering deep
learning is that there's less hand
designing of components needed and so
this could also simplify your design
workflow that you just don't need to
spend a long time hand designing
features and designing these
intermediate representations how about
the disadvantages here some the cons
first it may need a large amount of data
so to learn this x2y mapping directly
you might need a lot of data of X comma
Y and we've seen in a previous video
some examples of where you could obtain
a lot of data for sub toss um
for face recognition we could find the
raw data for finding a face in the image
as well as identifying the face once you
found the face but there was just less
data available for the entire end-to-end
task so you know x2 Suspiria input end
of the end and learning and Y is the
output and and so you need a lot of data
X Y with both the input and any output
and in order to train some of these
systems and this is why the content and
learning part as well because you're
learning a direct mapping from one end
of the system you know all the way to
the other end of the system the other
disadvantage is that it excludes
potentially useful and design components
so machine learning researchers tend to
speak disparagingly of hand designing
things but if you don't have a lot of
data then your learning algorithm
doesn't have damage insight you can gain
from your data if your training set too
small and so hand designing component
can really be a way for you to inject
nan your knowledge into the algorithm
and that's not always a bad thing I
think of a learning algorithm as having
two main sources of knowledge one is the
data and the other is whatever your hand
design being components or features or
other things and so when you have a ton
of data
it's less important to hand design
things but when you don't have much data
then having a carefully hand design
system can actually allow humans to
inject a lot of knowledge about the
problem into a into an algorithm and
that can I should be very helpful so one
of the downsides of entering deep
learning is that it excludes potentially
useful hand design components and
handles on components could be very
helpful of well-designed they could also
be harmful in a really limited
performance such as if you force an
algorithm to think in volumes when maybe
it could have discovered a better
representation by yourself so it's kind
of a double-edged sword that could hurt
or help but it does since home or hand
design components tend to home
or when you're training on a small
training set so if you're building a new
machine learning system and shuns inside
whether or not to use end to end deep
learning
I think the key question is do you have
sufficient data to learn a function of
the complexity needed to map from x to y
I don't have a formal definition of this
trace complexity meaning but intuitively
if you try to learn a function from X to
Y that is looking at an image like this
and recognizing the position of the
bones in this image then maybe this
seems like a relatively simple problem
to identify the bones in the image and
maybe don't need that much data collect
asked or given a picture of a person may
be finding the face of that person in
the image doesn't seem like that harder
problem so maybe they don't need too
much data to find the face of a person
or at least maybe you can find an
updated to solve that task whereas in
contrast the function needed to look at
the hand and map that directly to the
Asia reach out that seems like a much
more complex problem that intuitively
maybe you mean more data to learn if you
were to apply a pure end-to-end deep
learning approach so let me finish this
video with a more complex example you
only know that I've been spending time
hopping out an autonomous driving
company drive down AI so I'm actually
very excited about autonomous driving so
how do you build a car that drives
itself well here's one thing you could
do and this is not an end-to-end deep
learning approach you can take as input
an image of what's in front of your car
maybe radar lidar other sensor readings
as well but you know to simplify the
description let's just say you take a
picture of what's in front of what's
around your car and then to drive your
car safety you need to detect other
cause and you also need to detect
pedestrians
you need to detect other things of
course our pet will just present a
simplified example here having figured
out where are the other cars and
pedestrians you then need to plan your
own route so in other words if you see
where the other calls where the
pedestrians you need to decide how to
steer your own car what path to steer
your own car for the next several
seconds and then having decided that
you're going to drive a certain path
maybe if this is a top-down view of the
road you know that's your car maybe
you've decided to drive that path that's
what the powerful motor mount is then
you need to execute this by generating
the appropriate steering as well as
deceleration and braking commands so in
going from your image or your sensor
importance to detecting cars and
pedestrians that can be done pretty well
using deep learning but then having
figured out where the other cars and
pedestrians are going to you know select
this route exactly how you want to move
your car usually that's not done with
deep learning instead des done with a
piece of software called motion planning
and if you ever take a course in
robotics you learn about motion planning
and then having decided what the prop
you want to see your car through
there'll be some other algorithm I'm
going to say as a control algorithm that
then generates the exact decision that
then decides exactly how much to turn
the steering wheel and how much to step
on the accelerator or seven a break so I
think what this example illustrates is
that you want to use machine learning or
use deep learning to learn some
individual components and
supervised learning you should carefully
choose what types of XY mappings you
want to learn depending on what tasks
you can get data for and in contrast is
exciting to talk about a pure end-to-end
deep learning approach when you input an
image and directly output a steering but
given data availability and the types of
things we can learn with neural networks
today this is actually not the most
promising approach or this is not an
approach that I think teams have gotten
to work best and I think this is
actually this pure end-to-end deep
learning approach is actually less
promising then um more sophisticated
approaches like this given the
availability of data and our ability to
train your networks today so that's it
for end to end deep learning it can
sometimes work really well but you also
have to be mindful of where you apply
and end deep learning finally thank you
and Congrats on making it this far with
me if you finished last week's videos in
this week's videos then I think you
already be much smarter and much more
strategic and much more able to make
good proposition decisions in terms of
how to move forward on your machine
learning project even compared to a lot
of machine learning engineers and
researchers I see here in Silicon Valley
so congrats on all you've learned so far
and I hope you now also take a look at
this week's homework problems which
should give you another opportunity to
practice these ideas and make sure that
you're mastering them